but now that spring is sprung with Eve
going abroad an easy restaurant abroad
is Oh fraught with danger and a
judgement because we found a selection
of poor and sometimes fried eggs just
essentially lazy translations into
English on foreign menus okay so imagine
we're all in a restaurant together yeah
and I can understand so what are you
going to get and Stanley might reply
well I'm going to get the sausage and
the father-in-law
what could that possibly be
I don't know but the images that
conjures up it must be some sort of toad
in the hole yeah it's getting worse
it looks yeah this this is it I mean
really I mean I don't think anybody in
big relative in it yeah no you know and
I don't think anyone wants this German
type sexual harassment
but I don't think you can go wrong with
a nice place of hand shredded ask me Oh
everyone's favorite to add some more
just another handful you have look why
this is that savvy you know what wine
pairing menu oh this is a special brunch
for the weekend I might have the fresh
salad followed by a variety of opinions
almost imagine that on a menu under a
magical there's like parliament in there
serve in Parliament but then sometimes
people are just a bit lazy so this one
there's bigger menu there's some smoked
cow feet and then they just cow
something
there wasn't there just has something
just no beef in it but that person took
a bit of trouble this next person
couldn't be bothered to tall item number
two on the menu whatever food in it it's
too
okay Tonio dinner you meet again we move
on to dessert now ladies gentlemen oh oh
let's all let's all of a bowl of nuts
wits come
scag you can get strawberries miskova
you really want to push the boat out why
not have some chocolate puke
and finally is there anyone who live who
doesn't like sweet tight well
he translated New Vegas
a big big tradition there on Easter
Monday and this is fact is the girls big
to get whipped